[suspense music]
(host)
Some monsters call to
mind very specific images.
Their iconic onscreen
personas overshadow
their earlier histories.
I'm talking about Frankenstein
and his creature, Dracula;
the Invisible Man,
the Wolf Man, the Mummy.
Why is this?
Universal Pictures.
These famous Universal
monster faces
inspired decades of
Halloween costumes
and make up a distinctive
brand of horror
that defined early
Hollywood cinema.
With strategic decisions in
wardrobe and special effects,
uniform marketing,
innovative cinematography,
and casting that turned
everyday actors into stars,
Universal Pictures
forever changed the game
for onscreen monsters.
[suspense music]
At the turn of the 20th century,
early silent horror
films were largely
macabre European creations
featuring ghost skeletons
and wizards set against
gothic backdrops.
The 1922 German film "Nosferatu"
was a fitting fulfillment
of the Eastern European
vampire's legacy
and the first horror film
with an original score.
[ominous music]
But what is now considered
to be the canonical period
of horror cinema didn't come
about until Universal emerged
as a powerhouse
motion picture studio.
Founded in 1912, Universal
Film Manufacturing Company
initially saw critical
and financial success
but like most of America,
struggled during the
Great Depression.
The solution to
the studio's woes
came in an unexpected
form, monsters.
Universal's 1930s business
strategy started with a plan
to make movies on as
tight a budget as possible,
and horror fit the bill nicely.
The elements of gothic
storytelling combined swimmingly
with the low lighting and
imaginative camera tricks
that disguised budget
conscious sets.
Unknown actors
could be concealed
behind creative makeup effects,
and hiring
veteran European crew members
familiar with gothic work
made adapting spooky stories
for Hollywood easier.
With the horrors of World War
I and the Great Depression,
America adopted isolationists
policies alongside patriotism.
The monstrous figure
embodied outside threats
to these modern constructions,
literally entering the homes
of families to tear them
down from the inside.
[monster roars]
[Elizabeth screaming]
Other common themes in
Universal's golden age
of horror films included
the mad scientist hell bent
on playing God, the crumbling
ancestral home or castle,
class tensions,
failed marriages,
and challenges to
traditional gender roles,
all amidst a gothic setting
that alluded
to the historical but
evoked present day fears--
a clever way for
a studio to appeal
to what's already in
the minds of the people.
Universal's first venture
into horror began in 1931
with the infamous undead
blood sucker himself, Dracula,
an established character
in folklore and literature.
Both "Dracula" and "Nosferatu"
predate Universal's version
but Universal's "Dracula" was
the first to legally adapt
Bram Stoker's famous text.
After purchasing the
rights to both the novel
and theater adaptation
of "Dracula" in 1929,
studio executive Carl Laemmle,
Jr. green lit the film version
with a few caveats,
a tight budget,
prioritization of elements
from the stage play
and a short enough runtime
to use in a double feature.
Tod Browning was hired as
director and Charles D. Hall
was tapped for set design,
but the studio still
needed the star.
While other more famous
actors were considered,
Bela Lugosi stood out
as the logical choice.
He had played Dracula on
Broadway and he was cheap,
and thank the fates for that.
Lugosi's portrayal of the
count in Universal's makeup
and wardrobe became the most
influential visual portrayal
of vampires to this day.
The pale skin, dark, slick back
hair, aristocratic wardrobe,
an infamous cape, became
the iconic depiction
we frequently
associate with Dracula.
And even though many modern
interpretations of vampires
have moved past this portrayal,
the countless imitations
of the Universal brand,
not to mention the
Halloween costumes,
made this vampire an icon.
After the success of "Dracula",
Universal was thirsty
for another home run.
They offered prominent
director James Whale
a slew of different project
concepts to choose from
and he went with another
monster property,
Mary Shelley's "Frankenstein".
Like "Dracula" before it,
the movie success hinged
on the commercial
appeal of the monster.
Whale insisted on
casting Boris Karloff,
a noted but under-recognized
character actor
as the creature.
The neck bolts,
the exaggerated brow
and the suit were
a notable departure
from Mary Shelley's
original creation.
Yet the emotion that Shelley
wrote into the character
was still present
thanks to Karloff.
Universal's interpretation
would define both the actor
and Shelley's character
into the 21st century.
Take care, now, Frankenstein!
Take care.
(host)
And in the "Frankenstein"
film's final iconic face-off
between
Henry and his creature,
Universal continued to use
innovative cinematography
as a hallmark of the genre.
When the two gaze at each other
through the spinning wheel
of the windmill, the slats'
broken revelation of their faces
mimicking a film projector and
its precursor, the zoetrope.
[monster roars]
"Frankenstein" was the first
movie promoted by a studio
as a horror picture and
that decision was not met
without resistance,
primarily from Catholic
and conservative leaders.
Critics condemned a
controversial hanging scene
and some of the film's
dialogue as heretical.
Trying to address
these concerns,
Universal included a unique
prologue to the feature
condemning Frankenstein's
actions and warning the audience
of what they will see.
We are about to unfold
the story of Frankenstein,
a man of science who
sought to create a man
after his own image
without reckoning upon God.
(host)
Still, some newspapers refused
to publish ads for the film,
and censors demanded edits.
But the saying, any publicity
is good publicity worked here.
Made for less than $300,000,
"Frankenstein"
outperformed "Dracula,"
grossing $12
million domestically,
and Universal had another
successful monster.
In 1932, Universal drew
inspiration from recent events--
the discovery of the
tomb of King Tutankhamun.
His shrunken mummified corpse
captured the world's attention,
as did the rumored
accompanying curse.
"The Mummy" told
a tale of forbidden love
using the now
recognizable Boris Karloff
as a titular character.
With a powerful score and
clever shots of miniature sets,
viewers were transported
to an exotic interpretation
of Egypt that paid homage
to the undercurrent of magic
that fueled so many of film's
earliest gothic stories.
Like its Universal precursors,
"The Mummy" cinematic creativity
significantly contributed
to its historical permanence.
Pioneering cameraman Carl
"Papa" Freund moved the camera
in ways previously unseen.
He freed the camera from
the typical static tripod,
strapping it to his chest
for resting angles
and placing it on a crane
for expansive frames.
In 1934, Hollywood instituted
the self-imposed Hays Code,
responding to industry
scandals of the 1920s
and increasingly
boundary-challenging films.
These censorship
guidelines aimed to curtail
anything that didn't depict
the correct standards of life
as defined by the rich men
in charge at the time.
As a result, horror
didn't disappear on screen
but became a bit more subdued.
Universal, in spite of
the Hays Code, however,
still marketed
their films as shocking,
meant to astound and horrify,
which continued to
draw in audiences.
Universal went on to
add "The Invisible Man"
and "The Werewolf of London"
to their horror lineup,
bringing striking and
memorable special effects
to the screen--
not to mention two
more iconic monsters.
The monster genre couldn't solve
all of Universal's
financial struggles.
Burdened with debt,
Universal was bought out
by the Standard
Capital Bank in 1936,
and the existing
studio heads were canned.
New execs cut budgets
further, prioritizing musicals
and halting production
on new horror content,
leading to
an exciting development--
the introduction of
the horror sequel.
Eager to capitalize on their
earlier successes in the genre,
Universal produced
a whole host of sequels.
"Bride of Frankenstein,"
"Dracula's Daughter,"
"Son of Frankenstein,"
"The Invisible Man Returns,"
"The Mummy's Hand," "The Mummy's
Tomb," and "Son of Dracula."
These burgeoning franchises
were financially strategic
and further established
Universal's looming presence
in horror cinema.
Using a now established cast
and crew from makeup artists
to set designers, the visual
style of the Universal
horror film stayed consistent
and immediately recognizable.
Repeated visual and technical
cues like violent storms,
operating room or lab sets,
offscreen female screams,
large ancestral homes,
heavy use of shadows,
and creative cinematic
framework solidified the style.
Also in the 1940s,
Universal introduced
back-to-back crossover films
to the industry--
"Frankenstein Meets the Wolf
Man," "House of Frankenstein,"
and "House of Dracula."
These in-universe
collaborations
put the recognizable figures
of Frankenstein's creature,
Dracula, the Wolf Man,
the Mad Doctor
and the Hunchback assistant
together on screen,
like an Avengers-style universe
with fewer rules
and no shared history.
In the years following the
conclusion of World War II,
movie-going audiences seemed
to lose their appetite
for monster movies.
Perhaps needing a break from
violence and horror in general,
they opted for more uplifting
content at the box office.
The monster movies that
were made during this period
backed away from horror elements
and leaned into the comedic
potential of the genre.
In the 1950s,
while Universal Studios,
now Universal International,
continued to produce
horror films,
they prioritized science fiction
in response to world events
and audiences' shifting favor.
While the quality of
these films is debated,
there is little denying
that the decade contributed
at least one more unique and
iconic universal monster,
the "Creature from
the Black Lagoon."
They marketed the film
as the strangest
science fiction thriller
of them all,
hoping to attract
audiences enthralled
with the newly popular genre
and who were comfortable
with monster stories from
the previous two decades.
This monster isn't based
so much on existing lore
but does rely on a familiar
monster-as-human trope.
Set in the Amazon, the
half-fish, half-human monster
struggles with
very human feelings
of isolation and loneliness.
Called the Gill Man, the
notable and beautifully designed
character suit and
sophisticated makeup,
under the direction
of noted actress
and special effects
artist Milicent Patrick,
stand up as a hallmark
of Universal's monsters.
The film was also notable for
its underwater photography
not common for the time.
[suspense music]
It's not only a story that
makes a monster iconic.
All the creators who contributed
to Universal's classic
monsters did so
with a specific intention.
The writers, actors,
directors, cinematographers,
marketing executives,
special effects teams,
and costuming departments--
they formed the beating
or undead heart of these
silver screen interpretations.
I can't help but wonder
if the commercial
and critical failure of
some of the reboot attempts
is because they strayed too far
from the original
Universal monster formula.
Take 2017's "The Mummy"--
big-name,
A-list Hollywood actors,
huge budgets,
too heavy a reliance
on digital special effects,
and an obvious eye
on franchise tie-ins,
it neglected to honor the
monster and its meaning.
In my opinion, the magic
of the original films
comes from the forced
creativity necessary
of a smaller budget,
the gothic themes,
and letting the monster
and its story sell the film.
2020's "The Invisible Man"
came closer to this formula.
With a $7 million budget,
a fraction of "The Mummy"'s,
it uses the absence of the
monster's form--literally--
in favor of atmospheric tension
and some pretty horrifying
practical effects.
Universal's monsters pushed
back against societal norms,
often embracing the taboos
that rigidly defined
conventional American
social structures of family,
patriarchy, gender, and class.
While the golden age of
Universal classic monsters
is long gone, its legacy
has become monstrous itself,
enduring, frightening
and always there
to scare our
imaginations into action.
Ahoy, matey, the newest
show over on PBS Origins
will take you on
an enlightening voyage
through the pirate history
you've been missing.
"Rogue History" unravels
historical myths,
unearths lost narratives,
and champions unsung heroes.
It's the pirate history
you were never told.
Hit the link in the
description and explore it now.
- (speaker)Rolling?
- (host) Yeah.
(speaker) And action.
- Oh, no.
Oh, God. [laughs]
(speaker)
And action.
[host laughing]
I'm terrible.
- No!
- That was amazing.